Kotaku d-dan oopsy rice come day at a
new to see ray william johnson theater
news not ray william johnson what did he
do
SM ahead she's not really I'm done sir
bad if the lead and oopsie what's up
everyone it's your girl Gloria Borger
here to give you guys the hottest news
the freshest news the most reliable new
source of all time now I know I let you
guys down this very first story you
probably already know about it's not
funny if you already know about it but
just in case I'm gonna break it down
anyway I've been away a couple days okay
so I didn't follow this until I got back
but it's probably that the best thing
that it has has happened this year
Washington Post one of many that covered
the story wrote first a fast-rising
female if sports star was threatened
then she quit then she didn't exist very
curious hmm what do they mean by this
well the full story is basically this
this girl girl appear out of nowhere and
apparently was very good at overwatch
Wow
now personally I knew already that this
was fake because girls aren't good at
video games okay I know I'm not supposed
to give my opinion but I would even go
as far as to say his girls aren't even
video games I would even go as far as to
say girls aren't good at anything I
would even go as far as to say his girls
don't even exist well that was my
opinion of course which I'm not supposed
to give out to anyone and only think
girls really are good at is hosting the
news just kidding
so this girl that appeared out of thin
air and was really good at overwatch God
accepted into a pro team of over watched
just four days after she appeared out of
nowhere
Wow good for her and a lot of people
started to ask question you know why was
this person why does she you know just
appear out of nowhere why is there
barely any information or track record
of this person online
now as it turns out she was
unfortunately due to unforeseen
reactions Elly has opted to step down
from the Protein we hope you continue to
support her in her ventures in overwatch
as we will unforeseen reactions she has
a penis
now the story here is that it wasn't a
girl it was as a guy another overwatch
player called Punisher
now why would any guy pretend to be a
girl as a woman I just find that
completely appalling and disgusting and
this guy should be burned to the ground
he should be put in jail where he
belongs but that's just my opinion of
course now I know we're jumping a little
bit ahead here ok let's let's back it up
a bit so people didn't know that Ellie
was a guy a fake guy people didn't know
people thought it was an actual female I
know crazy right you know maybe just
maybe in hindsight it was kind of
obvious you know this person appears out
of nowhere doesn't give any information
about herself except the name Ellie okay
does not speak on stream right leaves
very briefly and does not list the full
name despite literally every other pro
player listing their full names the pro
team even themself listing her as you
know all the other players Rina VX
Justin Jian okawa Adrian cower real
corisco de le ah if up
stop asking if she's a real gamer or not
now I think it's pretty normal reaction
that in the pro players scene there's
only a certain amount of people if
someone appears I don't know we're not
giving aloud a lot of information it's
only natural that people are gonna ask
you know who is this person who is Ellie
there's even these conspiracy grabs were
that were trying to figure it out you
know oh we heard a female voice but she
says she will able to stream when she
gets a new PC then she can't stream
gameplay because her internet sucks how
does a new PC fix the problem calls
Punisher in this court to prove she's
not Punisher some people already weren't
figuring out who this person actually
was and it was a guy named Punisher
and the truth also then eventually came
out that this wasn't an actual female it
was a guy called Punisher and now this
other girl explained this that this was
the case le le the whole situation was
meant to be in a way like a social
experiment le is actually Punisher and
he told me yesterday
there you go okay so yeah le this game a
girl is a guy who can do and news
articles just couldn't fathom why how
could you do this Ford's posting on it's
still not clear on what point was
attempting to be proven with this social
experiment maybe the fact that this guy
Punisher can't join a pro team but then
as soon as he pretends to be a girl
literally for days and voila he's part
of a pro team Wow
you know this is why gamers needs to
rise up I've been saying this for
literally years no one cared who
Punisher was I think ooh taco said it
the best it's absolutely unacceptable
for members of this community to bully
her ass or Doc's players for their
gender it shows why there's so few women
in this sport we have to do better not
just for the women and girls playing
this game now but for those growing up
watching us who taco ran the story
saying overwatch Pro quits after
harassment over whether she was really
playing this poor woman all the
harassment that she got people just
wanted to know hey who are you are you a
real person the same thing would have
happened if it was a guy if a guy
disappeared I don't know where people
would ask the same question you know who
really is this guy and anyone that
practically called this person out this
fake persona le even in the slightest
got called out on Twitter for it we had
this this guy literally writing XD and
the response is professional overwatch
player for Paris eternal laughs about
they tagged his team so that he would
get some sort of replication laughs
about Ellie being bullied out of
contender's with daxing dressed
this is the problem with overwatch
League in all eSport all eSports this is
a problem I find it hilarious they you
you can't even scuff at this situation
because it's just harassment against
poor whamon that doesn't even exist you
know here's a question that I think is
worth asking with this whole thing is it
sexism or is it harassment if you're
asking a question and you happen to be
right obviously it looks bad if you
accuse someone of something if you have
no proof of it but that same argument
should apply if you're defending someone
without proof the internet and so many
of these news articles were so
desperately trying to defend Elly
without any proof of Elly even existing
or being a person people wanted Elly to
be real so desperately so they could
have a woman being harassed and run that
as a headline you know even after the
story is out there they still run the
story that it's a female gamer first a
fast-rising female esports star was
threatened there's they still go with
the same narrative yeah I like how in
hindsight this situation just a funniest
thing ever because you have people
posting this the fact that the team
didn't give out the name of other team
member and people saying like this the
fact that they did this is both
hilarious inside no it's just hilarious
yeah holy crap I'm sorry you have to go
through this people are so crappy le
posted that some guy on discord
it's weird referring her to le when it's
clearly just Punisher posted that some
guy on this court said that he was gonna
dog her and everyone just rushed to
defend this person how could how dare
you how dare you question the legitimacy
of this person how could you this poor
woman that doesn't exist I think we've
all learned a lesson here and that is
that gamer girls don't exist okay I've
been saying that for so long and I think
now finally we seal the deal here there
will be no more arguments the discussion
is over
case closed women aren't real everyone
thank you I'm Gloria Borger and this is
pew news
goodbye ah looks like we have more
stories battlefield 5 oh it's the end of
the saga it's the end of the season
the results are in we talked about
battlefield 5 it's been a running story
here on penis the first running story
basically first battlefield 5 reveal the
trailer it was garbage
then battlefield 5 said accept it or
don't buy the game well as it turns out
people didn't battlefield 5 physical
sales down more than half on battlefield
1 this is so sad why can't fake women
exist huh it's not too much to ask for
why can't my anime wife exist and be
real smh
a lot of people have been using the
argument for battlefield or at least
I've seen some people use the argument
that the reason why battlefield 5
underperformed was that there's so much
competition you know
red red redemption was out there's
competition every year ok the game did
badly because they marketed it extremely
poorly there's obviously other reasons
involved as well but I hope this is a
lesson to be learned and that is again
women aren't real how many times so I
gotta say this EA I think you need to
hire your girl I liked how they said I'm
fine with it
either or mix trailer you'll regret it
call six sexism in video games you'll
regret it
make good trailer you'll regret it well
they're definitely regretting this at
least smash like on this video right now
if you're a video gamer if you like to
play video games smash like and buy all
my merch right freaking now you will get
dowon on that TV and that's a fact
next story Jesus Christ needs your help
that's something I never thought I would
say you guys are probably familiar with
Jesus already he was involved during the
fiber scandal he does the fiber
announcement things where you can pay
him to save stuff but he's also been
very supportive of my channel and then
now Jesus needs your help
so Jesus drops the character more or
less apparently his real name is Jesus
Christ Jesus Christ
is jesus H Christ his real name is Jesus
Christ goddamn now he mentions that he
was grown up in a cult I was raised in a
highly controlled religious group some
people call it a cult it was because of
YouTube that I was able to learn the
truth about the organization that I had
dedicated my life to
so Jesus mentions that he is losing
custody of his children and that he
needs your help to be able to pay for
his lawyer and it's a very heartfelt
heartbreaking video and I can't keep up
with expenses anymore then this is my
only hope from losing my kids my lawyer
thinks this is my best chance and I
agree however it's very expensive and I
can't keep up with expenses anymore
I'm desperate I really need your help
I've set up a patreon and there's a link
in the description below and if you want
to support me you can do so for free by
subscribing liking this video and
sharing it with others Jesus has always
been nice to me he's always had my back
that sounds so weird to sing so I wanted
to at least repay the favor and link to
his patreon it's in their description if
you guys want to donate and help them
out Jesus has always had our backs it's
time for us to have Jesus backs back
next news rice gum rice gum yes of
course more rice gum yeah I love talking
about
so last week if you remembered basically
rice command Jake Paul promoted a brand
a website called misery brand which was
pretty obviously a scam
[Applause]
now I'm not supposed to give my opinion
but I thought I made it pretty well
thought out good video you know not just
calling out the fact that they're
promoting gambling to kids but also
pointing out that actual proof that this
website was bogus you know that they had
things that are pretty worthy of
actually calling it a scam and showing
that other youtubers have promoted this
website as well so rice got made a
response video saying this dude calls me
out for mystery unboxing I think he used
to be called PewDiePie calls me out for
mystery unboxing I guess he changed it I
don't know but basically I mean his
response was laughable I don't know why
I know why anyone would expect anything
else
honestly like three months ago don't
listen to anything it wasn't a problem
back then look look look all these guys
right here right there deep-ando rich
crew whatever they're influential got
kid fans same thing opened up bosses
this was three weeks ago way before I
was doing it why did no one bring it up
to three weeks ago or even talk about
these guys everyone else did it huh it's
not my fault everyone else stated why is
no-one calling them out yeah I did dips
okay I brought it up in my video Jesus
in Christ that doesn't change anything
the week is a response ever
I didn't even press that much that in my
video the fact that they're promoting
gambling to kids cuz I know Jake Paul
and rice scum don't give it obviously
they don't care they just want to make
money that's all that matters to these
people there's no reason to call them
out for anything unethical but if you
have something illegal that's gonna
reflect badly on everyone on YouTube
both their videos are still up you know
they both apologize more or less but
both their videos are still up and the
reason why is because more most likely
contractually they have to keep them up
for them to be paid they have to keep
the videos up so I think that pretty
much speaks for itself you know there's
nothing I can't really do let's say
sorry and
Amazon giftcard silk I'm sorry it's just
what had happened again Amazon cuz ten
to twenty dollars wow what an absolute
man light he gave away ten dollar gift
cards that fixes the whole thing is he
serious or is he trolling I can't tell
it's so moronic imagine saying that you
got over a hundred thousand dollars and
then spending five hundred dollars being
like we're cool now right the least of
convivial you but he doesn't want to
person not going to do that and then
someone even found out that these gift
cards they weren't even legit they've
been cashed literally months ago and
what they was s12 okay that's all I
needed I just had to check if there were
anyone where acted with great good job
you can't even spend five hundred
dollars not even that Jesus Christ I
doubt he was even paid a hundred
thousand I mean it's entirely possible
but I mean I don't want to say it but
they offered keemstar one honey can I
know I feel like I have a guess
somewhere between 200 and 250 thousand
dollars listen he's Rice gum would 100%
point out that he made more than
keemstar right this is rice gum we're
talking about here he would definitely
point out going like yeah I won't say
how much but more than what keemstar
made that's what he would say it doesn't
matter how much money is involved it
doesn't matter what he says as a
response or what he tries to do only see
the leaks that can video at this point
people already know about Jake Paul
people don't really know by Ryan scum
they are their counter scumbags okay
people it's already a known fact that
that's why when this the whole thing
came out people were jumping all over
this story because they can call that
rice scum and they can call out Jake
Paul which is not really that hard to do
no one genuinely likes them ironically
you know when when rice gum deflects to
other people doing the same thing you
know it's a apology but he also kind of
have a point why did no one care about
all these other youtubers doing this
thing I think it was the same thing with
better helps so many people promoted
better help and most likely
they did it because they saw someone
else promoted and didn't think twice
about it they just thought well other
people are promoting this so I can do it
as well right and that's kind of the
problem you need to look into these
things yourself and at least take a
responsibility when it comes out about
it because even with better help you
know when the story came out that it's
kind of a shady website a shady service
a lot of people took action that had
promoted better help they did the right
thing you know but so many people didn't
people were just silent and didn't make
any reaction or deflect that as well I
don't think anyone is surprised by the
reaction of rice command Jake Paul they
obviously don't care it doesn't end of
story I mean there's nothing else to say
about it I think that's literally it
there's a bigger story that I want to
bring up but I we're out of time and I
think I'll make something I'll make just
one video on the topic and a little hint
for the future thank you guys so much
for supporting Pio news March up in the
description and I'll see you guys next
time this is Gloria Borger signing off
[Music]